Hôm hoàn Nam Pian, có chủ tịch hội đồng trường đại học F-T,
lột ngọt qua đời vào lúc người sáo dở mười phút ngày 30 tháng bài,
vì ngừng tiêm lột ngọt.
Sinh Nam Một Nền Chính Cham Sáo Mí Chính,
ông hoàn Nam Pian, sất thân từ một gia đình có chuyển thống cách mặt khi là con uốt
của cố théo tưởng hoàn đàn và nguyên đại biểu có khội nguyên thị ăn vình.
Ông Pian tốt nghiệm ngành công nghệ thông tiên tài đại học Vách Hoa Hàn Nội,
Nam Một Nền Chính Cham Chính, Mì Bà,
sau đó, ông ra nhập tập loạn F-T và gắn bỏ với xanh nghiệp công nghệ hàng đầu Việt Nam cho đến nay.
Chồng sốt bà mì hai năm qua, ông hoàn Nam Pian đã trải qua nhiều vị trí
tại nhiều xanh nghiệp thành viên trong tập loạn F-T.
Bên cảnh phai trò xuân nhân, chuyên gia công nghệ nhà giáo, thời gian qua, ông hoàn Nam Pian,
cũng nhận được nhiều sự yêu mến với từ cách là một cố vấn trong hoạt động hình nghiệp,
hãy giữ giả tại nhiều sự kiện lớn.
Ông cũng là tác giả của quấn, thư cho em,
sức bản vào tháng 3 năm 2, in không trăm 2 mì thứ,
kể lại công chuyện tình yêu của Bố Mẹ ông qua hơn 40% là thứ được Việt trong thời viến tranh.
Gần nhất, hồi tháng 6, ông ra mất sách ứng dụng AI vào vân nghiệp.